[Musique]
une mystérieuse agence de communication
a demandé à plusieurs stars du web qu il
décrédibilise le vaccin father à
brochets les eaux grasses est
spécialiste scientifique a refusé 2000
euros et révèle sur la toile les
coulisses de larnaca vraiment des trucs
qui m'ont choqué en grèce ne nie pas que
cette vidéo est sponsorisé une vidéo
rémunérés avec un budget présenté comme
considérable à condition de terre la
somme à la clé l'argumentaire cette
opposition entre astrazeneca pfizer le
côté tirer vos propres conclusions
cette rhétorique qui effectivement issu
des théories du complot me fait penser à
comment la russie comme unique autour du
vaccin unique cinq sprints shepard on
sait pas si ça vient de france ou
l'étranger
j'en sais rien je me permettrai pas de
partir de faire des hypothèses c'est
minable c'est dangereux
c'était irresponsable et ça ne marche
pas la vente c'est une filiale d'adp now
une entreprise de communication
implantée à moscou en caméra discrète
nous nous rendons dans leurs locaux on
nous répond d'abord
je ne sais pas mais c'est pas ici mais
devant le bâtiment
deux employés nous confirme travailler
pour ada ho il y a un département qui
travaillent avec des blogueurs
j'assume totalement ses propos les
répertorier je les respecterai et les
répèterai je le répète aujourd'hui ce
type de propos doit être sanctionné par
les électeurs
donc j'appelle les franciliens à ne pas
voter pour madame pulvar y est déposé
plainte à la place de l'ange noir a
déposé plainte je pense que la justice
compte tenu de tout ce que je viens de
vous dire a objectivement autre chose à
faire cette plainte
elle n'a qu'un but c'est de faire de la
politique c'est d'instrumenter la mort
de ces policiers pour en faire un
argument politique etc de m'intimider
ça ne marche pas ça ne m'intimide pas ça
ne m'impressionne pas en revanche cela
m'inquiète pour l'état de notre
démocratie
le même homme va maintenant se permettre
de chercher à intimider une candidate
pour des propos qui n'ont rien de
diffamatoire
on a le droit dans ce pays puisque nous
sommes en démocratie de prononcer un
avis sur une manifestation qui s'est
tenue que s'est déroulée parce que je
suis noir
je dénonce un certain nombre de choses
alors tout de suite ça me catégorise
parmi les indigènes hisser le racialisme
je vais vous dire les indigéniste ils me
haïssent les racialiste ils me haïssent
ils me traitent de négresse de maison je
trouve que voilà il fait une opération
de communication politique et le
ministre de l'intérieur je suis pas sûr
que ça lui serve parce que personne
n'est dupe de cette opération
faute de résultat par ailleurs on le
voit bien il court après l'événement ils
surent communiquent mais on sait très
bien qu'à une règle en france on l'a vu
d'ailleurs avec emmanuel macron et avec
ses deux youtuber plus on communique
c'est parce que moi on a des résultats
j'ai entendu ce matin les propos de
madame audrey pulvar sur lci explicitant
clairement que pour elle la police
n'était pas raciste
j'en prends acte je lui propose de la
rencontrer dans les prochains jours est
ce que nadine morano et eric ciotti
feraient de bons ministres d'une
présidente marine le pen pourquoi pas
mais pourquoi pas vous les prendre il
propose rien souhaitais que vous les
sentez plus proche de vous ou plus
proche des manuels mag ronge
les sens plus proche de moi que d'
emmanuel macron dit je sais ça me paraît
clair fabien qui est un laxisme et
l'hyper violence aujourd'hui c'est le
produit de cette hyper laxisme mieux
lutter contre le trafic de drogue la
volonté du ministre de l'intérieur qui a
annoncé hier l'instauration d'une amende
de 135 euros pour les guetteurs ce qui
alerte les trafiquants de drogue de
l'arrivée de la police
mon conjoint ne travaille plus pour moi
je rappelle que mon conjoint et
travailler 80 heures par semaine
il aura donc fait deux 2 semaines en
travers en 80 heures par semaine
gratuitement thériault - ya peu il n'y a
pas de conflit d'intérêts alors
intérieurement elle va beaucoup
travailler pour vous barclays écoutez je
ne connaissais pas au mouvement il est
arrivé à mon cabinet donc encore une
fois voyez c'est une atteinte à la vie
privée qui est extrêmement désagréable
on sait juste processus seconde fenêtre
une caméra dans ma chambre à coucher